[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
We recently released a
new spatial audio software
development kit called
Resonance Audio.
It's based on technology
from Google's VR Audio SDK,
and it works at scale across
mobile and desktop platforms.
Links to the docs and GitHub
are on the post linked
in the description below.
Fast Pair is a
hassle-free process
to pair your Bluetooth devices
on all supported Android
devices running Google Play
services 11.7 and later,
with compatibility
back to Marshmallow.
Check out the post for an
example of how it works.
We have added support
for high-availability
and read replicas in Cloud
SQL for PostgreSQL, which
will help ensure your database
workloads are fault tolerant.
Diagrams and details
are on the post.
The first Google Cloud Platform
region in India is now open.
Hosting applications
in the new region
can improve latency from 20% to
90% for end users in the area
compared to hosting
them in Singapore.
We recently introduced Eager
Execution for TensorFlow.
It's an imperative,
defined-by-run interface
where operations are
executed immediately
as they are called from Python.
This makes it easier to
get started with TensorFlow
and can make research and
development more intuitive.
Code and all the
links are on the post.
Oh, and in case you missed
it, Firebase Predictions
is now available to build
dynamic user groups based
on predicted behavior determined
using a machine-learned model.
These user groups
can then be targeted
using Firebase Cloud Messaging,
Remote Config, and more.
To learn how to use Firebase
Predictions for your app,
check out the post linked
in the description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everybody.
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of "The Developer
Show."
If you'd like to catch
some of our prior episodes,
check them out right over here.